et bien autant j'ai eu d'intérêt et de
curiosité pour doha de manège
autant j'ai eu d'amitié et d'amour et
j'ai toujours d'amitié et d'amour pour
casque d'heure qu'est-ce que d'or c'est
un peu ridicule de dire sa vie je vais
te dire quand même cascadeur c'est un
film que j'aime exactement comme si je
ne l'avais pas fait vous savez quand
nous autres nous revoyons nos films où
on nous regardons nous d'enfants c'est
comme ça que ça se passe je crois pour
presque tous les acteurs qu'est-ce que
d'heures non cascadeur jeu c'est le seul
je crois des films que j'ai faits que
j'aime comme si je l'avais pas fait je
sais pas si je me fais bien comprendre
enfin je veux dire par là que je subis
le charme de casque je m'appelle sa vie
devient de plus en plus ridicule parce
que tout de même suite dedans mais ses
très sincères quand je dis ça c'est
vraiment un film qui a pour moi un gr
mystérieux je subis comme si je l'avais
pas tourné dans qu'est ce que d'heures
je vais pas encore vous répéter qu'on
s'est amusé parce que vous finiriez par
croire que dans le monde
s'agit que de s'amuser en faisant ce
métier c'est un peu voire ya aussi
d'autres choses il faut une fatigue et
quelques fois il fait très froid et on
tourne avec une très légère et
quelquefois et les horaires sont durs et
m'enfin avant le c'est quand même très
bien bon alors dans casse